you know what a Harlequin is the  Harlequins role is to serve it's nothing  without a master no one gives two shits  who we are beyond death  [Music]  the Joker and I broke up I wanted a  fresh start but it turns out I wasn't  the only daemon got them looking for  emancipation  spectacular new  Miss Quinn she brought me  [Music]  who are you guys  [Music]  [Applause]  you're still quick you need me  after all of us now none of us are  walking out of here  we work together  [Applause]  just like a sleepwalker  we should order pizza because  [Applause]  [Music]  the one they should be scared of not you  not mr. J because I'm  who's having a good time  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  well you psycho jerk they've never call  a woman a chick I'll accept fraud lady  woman but on occasion [ __ ] h3e talking  about for anyway  [Music]  you